good morning K well it's seven o'clock
this morning uh Israeli times about 5
a.m your time Israeli forces acting on
what I'm told by a senior military
commanders was precise intelligence to
use their words uh went uh into the old
city of Nablus uh into the Casbah area
and they surrounded a house which
contained the two wanted terrorists and
one of their assistants as well a
gunfight ensued and they shot the three
men dead the whole operation lasted for
around an hour and they've confirmed
that two of those killed were indeed the
two terrorists who shot dead Lucy Maya
and Rina D the British Israelis who were
traveling through the West Bank up to a
holiday in Lake Galilee last month well
I've spoken to Rabbi Leo D the husband
of Lucy and the father of Maya and Rina
he's told me this morning that he and
his children are delighted to hear that
virus were apprehended and eliminated
and most of all that it was done in a
way that didn't endanger the lives of
Israeli soldiers I also interviewed him
exclusively last month and he said in it
that quite extraordinarily he didn't
hold any hatred towards the men who'd
killed his family members
uh but this morning he also uh told me
that he would if he ever had the
opportunity uh like to ask the family
members of those terrorists uh what it
was all uh in Aid of and what they hoped
to achieve and how there could ever be
peace uh when their family members act
like that so A major development this
morning in what was an ongoing Manhunt
the Prime Minister Billy Netanyahu has
just released a statement as well uh
congratulating the Israeli Security
Forces but another uh incident in the
West Bank in the old city of Nablus
three gunmen dead Palestinian gunman
dead two of those as I say The Wanted
terrorists who shot dead those three
British Israelis last month